eine dame reale sind gerade 9 uhr
irgendwie haben doch auf eine youtube
daily talk hat die un-mission karte
haben aber ich habe ich die karte
schauen die drei ja gerade hier auf
toilette radiert nicht ein paar karten
kassiert und irgendwie sind alle haare
in den körperlichen zu behaupten
war ja klar freunde wird auf jeden fall
sein hat mir wert von 10 ich machen
darauf werden wir im paradies was
bestücken danach werden wir einen
rücktritten der 6,7 millionen forderung
auch instagram ich schon traurig da
andere youtuber schön mit irgendwelchen
dafür nicht schultern häuser einfach mit
dem hund aber der hund ist auch ins
david reform fall verdient weil wir
zusammen machen wollen derweil plant
sein dass wir uns noch mit rotwild und
barak treffen glaube ich und danach
einfach den ganzen tag am start sein
werden
ich will die leute gehen und einen
burger finden wird in deutschland nicht
gibt
doch schon längst angefangen das wetter
soll heute in 28 grad werden
wir sind hier der letzten donnerstag
daher befürchtet heute sind es tagen
brummt und auch heute nur noch jeder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
irgendwie dollar viele sicher und sich
gewünscht dass du mehr redet und mehr zu
wort kommt in dem blog seite möchten was
sagen die kenner wes angeles habe ich
irgendwie vermissen die verstopften habe
ich mir so einen nasenspray und komisch
ist im supermarkt kaufen wird es hat
einfach vergessen
genauso kann man die durch ist die gurke
odilia filmt und ich wäre einfach was
sie dort auf die welt kommt der focus
wird wieder eifrig fakt ist so hab ich
hab doch auf dem blog ich habe heute
morgen angefangen hast du ja voll regnet
werde ich mal heute blogger der focus
machte immerhin strich durch die
rechnung jetzt geht er wieder klar
wahrscheinlich wenn ich jetzt wieder den
boden firmenehe genau wieder klar wenn
ich das hier oben filme geht er auch
klar wenn ich mich dann warum es zum
beispiel darum nicht da hinten ist
übrigens dass mehr aber wir gehen hätte
wusste wo es der pokal blamage
jung ich wusste dass das kommt alter auf
einmal mitten auf der straße begonnen
wochen markierten die tasche greifen
einfach eine kartoffel bei kartoffeln
also das ist unser essen salaten nur wie
eine protein borkum türkei alles klar
was ich sagen wollte war sie davon
halten würde wenn ich mit jungen die
neue woche
wir sind gerade kurz wieder noch helfen
angekommen weil dort immer nur sachen
angezogen haben wir jetzt den hund
gehört werden was ich euch übrigens
fragen wollte war was sie davon halten
unit wänden mark und ich uns irgendwie
im september oder so mal hier in santa
monica irgendwie so verein zwei wochen
eine wohnung mieten würden und blogs
machen würden falls du darauf haben
sollte dann nach jedem fall mike da und
ich hatte mir doch nicht schaffen
10 millionen
das trio nicht klar wer wollte ich
wollte freundlich zu schütteln weil der
unterhalt ihrer bisschen gestresst
bekanntlich eine auf kostet eben fehler
hin zu kriegen also die seht ihr auf
jeden fall hin 260 sogar schon kleinere
in ostbevern stand aber mit viel auf
youtube nicht mehr verkauft jetzt mit
amerikanischen wir warten jetzt noch
wenig öl und werden uns dann sind
irgendwelche komischen speicher
wohnungen mega geil hier alte man kann
hier somit bei kupfer auf diesem wege
gefordert sind sowohl über alfelder der
strand dahinter freizeitpark zu dem wir
glaube ich auch noch irgendwo hingehen
aber wir werden jetzt auch nicht auf die
fahrt wird mit wecker drei minuten
dauern
egal wie schön dieser strand und wie
schön die aussichten pizza sondern auch
der schönste auf der welt ihren die
fahrräder abgegeben und schöne tier am
strand
das ist gerade der ausleger so die sonne
ist da wollte sie nicht gesehen habt
hier haben wir machen den sonnenschirmen
komisch anderer leute rettung
demontieren da hinten sind die alpen da
kann man super gut skifahren im winter
ich habe mega boxmeer zu gehen aber wohl
berichtet es ist kälter als lebens-
unfall- dafür wurde von vielen leuten
getragen dass das was soll das
daraus
der fahrzeughalter
das unterbecken baby fremde haut häufig
dollar zurück
[Musik]
ich muss immer viele leute einfach so
schön hier gerade aber die laufenburger
laden übrigen piloten unterwegs
felix bilder gemacht
eine kamera dienstag luca genau
abonniert wenn ihr denkt dass ich der
beste blocker auf der welt wird im video
was ich sagen wollte war dass wir auf
jeden fall jetzt zu der frage kommen die
zu beginn des blogs schon gesagt habe
und zwar werden mac donalds ihr und ich
werde die nach einem bürger fragen die
nicht nur amerika
ich habe gerade eine dating bacardi
werden könnte stellte bürgerlichen
angestellten deutschland liegt
die integrierte land hält
[Gelächter]
es tut gut wieder angekommen
ich vertrage ich packe bei den bürgern
nicht gesponsert von denen oder so
manchem zeit anzusehen welche sachen das
einfach nicht zu hause geht also dass
solche wachstum ohne leim diesem band
crazy chicken viele bürger dass jetzt
die verpackung reduziert eigentliche
reiz ausmachen ich fange sachen raus und
sehen schon alter bei der die
tatsächlich ganz gut aus wir fuhren
jetzt erfahren wir heute eigentlich ein
burger ist wie mancher bürger heute
mitteilte alles klappt wirklich eine
scheibe drauf geklatscht wurde ihr
werdet live dabei wie ich einen burger
essen die mir so nicht in deutschland
gibt
und beim teilen risiken bei mcdonalds
oder fast food oder zwischendurch mit
drei bis zehn grad aber an der starken
mega gut also ganz einfach avocado traut
wird die chicken und weder brötchen
essen schlafen deutschland wirklich
nicht meisten heutigen tag unbedingt in
amerika bin weil ich weiß nicht mal wie
der blog heutige fall natürlich nicht
selber like freunde amerikas erlebte
waren
wir haben
[Musik]